oops hi hello and welcome to this video
didn't didn't we recognize that the game
is started so let's see what we get
nuzzo and queens too okay d 5 is a good
line one of the one of the main lines
how do i play again probably with III
yeah hmm that's a line that I haven't
looked it for a very long time I had
this on the board in some recent games
but I remember that it didn't get much
like is some having rather active pieces
I might even be able to play a five no
he doesn't okay yeah it's hard to avoid
the trade yeah I guess trading the nine
push up d 393 bishop age seven hmm i
don't know if that is a good idea no i
don't i don't really think so let's play
normal motion
yeah here blacks equalizing chances are
very very good counseling for rookie one
yet five is the most active most active
move that black can go for to develop
the bishop actively i'm not sure if it
is the best move to be honest something
more modest also um was an option okay
95 okay Queen a five I guess now maybe
I'll start with this move asking way is
going Bishop H 595 is a little bit more
annoying and it takes on f3 and okay so
isn't this a little bit annoying let's
see what happens here
I either get a 94 on get the bishop back
to f3 which also is a bit more
comfortable for white like Queen g5
bishop f3 should be a slight advantage
greene takes h5 this 90 form not sure
that this is really a lot but 95 or 96
are possible options yeah I hope the aid
however is a problem which texts my rook
it's not so ideal
yeah maybe queen should be three here to
cover the Roca check be seven and there
are some possible ideas also with 96 m
hmm no it's not totally totally easy if
I am to do okay Queen g6 downlight c5 is
a move and yeah just wonder if there is
something better than 95 can also play
f3 and simply keep the knight on e4 I
don't know if that is any good the text
b7 so it's not completely pointless yeah
maybe the weekend b3 porn is a problem
but yeah it's not that looks bad okay
Wow okay let's play Lucy one yes but
yeah I thought isn't the night somewhat
somewhat offside he has f5 if he wants
to really get rid of my iphone light but
93-95 is coming no it's not that's not
so easy him okay so um um maybe not so
quick yeah but it looks it looks okay to
bring the night to d5 quite least
introduce that idea okay if I do it now
yeah in a six even a screen be 60 now
that mattress platform to to make this
night a lot more stable
hmm that'd really looks like there
should be some kind of tactic here but I
don't see it I don't see one I sasukes
you want okay I'm starting with this he
has to check with the rook and now
yeah I don't know it looks good but I
don't see don't see something decisive
just covering the night very likely not
the best move but I didn't see something
really great okay so it's a ticket
yeah expecting no I was expecting the
other move okay so i can take time
morning check night will take three to
excess 97 maybe you can even play that
as weird as it looks so nice cheeks so
we will call 96cm I want to try to pin
them down with this okay I'll always
actually threatening to take okay
I don't see a way forward him is there
some way forward I cannot go anywhere
here I can try really Queen to d8 set
possible maybe I'm gambling too much
here I wish I has a oops now I can take
that I was a mouse live Queen have to or
smile resign I think we have to was a
draw I'm threatening meeting myself on g
ade that was the only way that I saw to
avoid the draw yeah he says I meant
Queen f2 yeah that was a draw i guess
hmm I so I didn't didn't manage to
refute this and there should be there
should be something yeah okay the engine
says d4 is a lot better maybe because
here taking is a bad idea as the night
can also take oh yeah this is strong yes
the bad night only five so white should
have something and this is better yeah
it really is the stock fish engine wants
to play something like that but here why
this is really a lot better okay I went
in cheeks and your form yeah White
House's has some like it gives her a
pawn so it but it's not really that much
create a sixth now the computer move
quickly the pawn yeah maybe this is good
damn
he expected 96 and not this which I felt
was for shaky and it is shaky but
because of this yeah this threatens the
a7 power now it's easy actually the a
7-pole and it threatens Quincy 897 so
something like this is forced and he I'm
winning the porn forum for not much hmm
now that's a lot better yeah and this is
a survey from yeah this is okay it's a
draw I tried this which might be dicey
yeah it is dicey actually now it takes
Queen d8 check and okay this is a small
slip queen ever check check Jamie gives
the chicks here can can can black
somehow of course you can go to F sub
chat now of course they can just go here
f6 I mean ha wow so I was gambling
completely and totally unjustified very
lucky I didn't see night have 60 it was
bad yeah I missed some chances earlier
but the way it panned out he should have
yeah but even I mean he mouth slipped
the Queen in this situation you're
blackish is kitty but I said didn't see
that the night can come back to have six
I wasn't him I wasn't aware of that okay
well thanks for watching